-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everyone.
During what continues to be
a very turbulent time,
I just want to say
to everyone out there protesting
or people going back to work
during quarantine,
please stay safe.
And we appreciate you.
We have a great show tonight.
The co-hosts of "Queer Eye"
are on the show tonight.
And their new season
just came out on Netflix.
And we saw episode one,
and it is just great.
They are just -- it's --
it's almost --
it's comforting,
but it's heartbreaking.
It's beautiful.
It's great.
And that was only
halfway through it.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, even to the end
is just -- yeah.
It's fantastic.
But we love all of those guys,
so they're on the show tonight,
as well as Christian Slater,
who has a new show on USA,
Tuesdays, at 10:00.
And, honey, you'll like it.
It's, like, season two
of "Dirty John."
It's a real --
-Oh, I'm in.
-Yep.
And then our music tonight,
she's unbelievable.
And Sia is on the show tonight.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
She has a motion picture
called "Music,"
and the song's called
"Together."
And Sia is one -- I wish --
you know, I miss seeing
these people and being
in front of these singers.
'Cause it's people
like Sia that --
And musicians will know
what I'm talking about --
She almost doesn't need
a microphone
when she's performing.
She's so good and, like,
projecting, and it's like, wow!
It's powerful.
And I'm always like, "Wow.
Were you even using the mic?"
'Cause she fills up
the whole room.
And I remember
even her doing "Chandelier,"
I want to say, and I was like,
"You're not gonna
hit those notes."
It was like --
[ Whistling ]
I can't even whistle it,
what she was singing.
♪ Chandelier ♪
And she hit all the notes,
and I was like, "Ah!"
She is just amazing.
So, what a great show tonight.
And thank you so much, again,
for watching.
Let's get to some news.
Well, you guys, it's another
rough week for President Trump.
Though at this point,
I can just say,
"Well, you guys, it's another
week for President Trump."
CNN just released
a new poll yesterday,
and it doesn't look too good
for the President.
-President Trump's
approval rating is the lowest
it's been since January
of last year.
That's according
to a new CNN poll
that shows the President
slipping amid a chaotic week.
Only 38% approve
of the job he is doing.
That is down 7 points
since just last month.
-Ouch.
Right now, the only thing
lower than Trump's
approval rating
is his underground bunker.
38%, to put that in perspective,
more people approved
of Lay's cappuccino-flavored
potato chips.
Cappuccino-flavored
Incidentally, 38% is
the same ratio of chips to air
in every bag
of Lay's potato chips.
It's bad. Right now,
even the "New York Times"
op-ed section has more fans.
[ Chuckles ]
You know
how I know things are bad?
Earlier today, Don Jr.
changed his name to Eric.
[ Laughs ]
And now Trump
wants to improve his numbers
by getting his campaign team
from 2016 back together.
Trump was like, "We can do it.
They're all out of prison now.
So..."
Speaking of Trump's campaign,
it looks like he's ready
to get back out on the road.
-And now the President
is planning
to get back out on the trail.
His campaign says
they're looking to resume
those big rallies
in the next two weeks,
despite concerns
about the pandemic.
-Don't worry.
Just to be safe,
everyone gets injected with
bleach on the way in and out.
So...
Actually, Trump said that
they're being smart.
He was like,
"When the rally ends,
everyone will have
to stay in the arena
for two weeks of quarantine."
So, that's fair, right?
Meanwhile, just when it seemed
like things
couldn't get any more upsetting,
Trump took to Twitter
this morning
to offer a conspiracy theory
of the police-brutality incident
in Buffalo.
He said that the 75-year-old man
who was shoved by the police
could be an ANTIFA provocateur.
And, "I watched.
He fell harder than was pushed.
Could be a setup?"
Yeah, it's pretty interesting
that this guy
is giving a lesson on gravity,
from a man who stands like this.
It's almost like he's, like,
free falling,
like one of those
flying squirrel guys.
♪ Defying gravity ♪
Um...
After receiving criticism from
both Democrats and Republicans
for that exact tweet,
Trump followed up by tweeting,
"Make America great again."
'Cause when the new stuff bombs,
you got to go with the hits.
Well, I saw
that Daniel Radcliffe
released a statement condemning
J.K. Rowling's
controversial tweets
about trans people.
Many people have been surprised
about her views,
but I don't know.
If you go back and read
the "Harry Potter" books,
it kind of makes sense.
There's a character
that I forgot totally about.
There's Hermione, Ron, Harry,
and, of course,
there was the fourth friend
that I forgot called Whimpleton.
I totally --
Well, here's a couple excerpts
from the audiobooks.
Should make more sense.
Listen.
♪♪
-"We have to stop
Professor Snape
from getting
the Babbling Thwoggit!"
exclaimed Harry.
"Grab your wands!"
cried Hermione.
"I'm just gonna say it.
I'm not totally sold
on this whole 'trans' thing,"
said Whimpleton.
"Not the time, Whimpleton!"
yelled Harry. "Wow!"
"Use the Portkey
to get to the Jackalion!"
declared Hermione.
"What kind of creature is that?"
inquired Ron.
"Does it have claws and sharp
teeth?" queried Harry.
"And is it a boy or a girl?
It has to be one, not neither
or both," said Whimpleton.
"Whimpleton, literally no one
asked for your opinion here!"
shouted the group.
"We've only found 16 of the
cursed Nobbilynooks!"
Ron gasped.
"We have to hurry!"
bellowed Harry.
"But wait!"
Whimpleton halted.
"Can I just say, the thing
about menstruation is --"
He never got
to finish his sentence,
as Hermione pulled out her wand
and transfigured him
into a tea cozy
And at last,
Whimpleton was useful.
But people are thanking
Daniel Radcliffe
for speaking out against
J.K. Rowling's tweets.
It's an easy issue to get wrong,
so just so everyone's
on the same page,
here's a complete list
of all the things
people want to hear
J.K. Rowling's take on.
♪♪
-Wizards.